God has a special plan for you it's not
contingent upon whether other people do
what they were supposed to do or if
other people are successful or not it's
just you and your plan and you competing
with yourself and you getting better
than your former self don't get me wrong
we're all connected but this idea that
somebody can take something from me
That was supposed to be mine
I don't believe that I think that the
only person that can hinder you is you
and no one's gonna steal well my
business would have grown if it wasn't
for that guy over there no you there was
probably something you were supposed to
do well if it wasn't for you know
student loans I could have been Rich by
now no it's probably like I don't
believe that somebody can steal like
your purpose and your what's meant for
you from you I don't know is that
controversial no no I I I I just love
the idea of it
there's enough there's enough there's
enough there's enough what's for you is
for you but you got to be the one to go
out and get it